there's a fungus growing under the
streets of Paris and it's edible the
cool damp caves and catacombs of the
French capital are the perfect breeding
ground for the humble button mushroom
and Joel maoli is one of just five
farmers left in this traditional trade
is an opposite or gospel is its
difference here because we still operate
the traditional way there is your
mushrooms first of all should be grown
close to Paris then we use an ancient
method and I do everything myself I hand
it was Napoleon who first moved the
Capitol's mushroom reduction down to the
catacombs but the construction of the
Paris underground drove many farmers out
and cheap imports filled the gap but
Paris mushrooms are back on plates
around the city thanks to the trend of
eating local organic food that may
champignon Bowie
they're called Paris mushrooms and
they're from Paris which is really rare
these days all the Paris mushrooms on
the market these days come from
countries outside of France there aren't
a lot of mushroom farms left in Paris so
it's really important to be working with
products like these Kay farmers want to
give the Paris mushroom similar
protection to champagne so only products
from the region can be given the name
when an unquantifiable
we are working on building a quality
label in order to communicate and give
recognition to this method of production
so if you find yourself peckish in Paris
a taste for the underground could be on
the menu for you
you